I want to get your reaction to a short
clip and then from there you can give me
give us your thoughts and we can drive
some benefit hopefully show no Jeff I'm
doing okay you know I ain't doing number
living life you know I live a great life
lavish life keep a [ __ ]
you having to keep a pocket full of
money as you can see if you had a
sit-down you had an opportunity to talk
to someone like this a floyd minute
money maybe they kind of employed money
Mayweather or someone famous like that
what kind of things what would you tell
them Salam alaikum
welcome to the D show greetings of peace
and I'm gonna wish the chef who's with
me guess who's with us reuniting after
such a long time Sheikh Ibrahim Sedan
how are you how are you Sheikh
traveling all over the place huh well
let them make it easy unaccept powder
you looking good to you - masha'Allah
may Allah bless you and continue to
preserve you doing some wonderful work
out there let's start off with so how
you been in general everything is good a
little yeah you know what let's start
off with that because obviously from the
time we've seen each other it's been
over a couple years at least right and
last time we got together we spoke about
a topic that it's encouraged for us to
talk about we talked about deaf have you
had any I've had some some family that's
passed have you had any stories that
have touched you or some events in your
life that can bring some benefit to us
that relates around this this topic and
also to some also there are many
actually the more we live this subject
of death becomes part of it is from the
revelation from Allah it's clear and
we're encouraged to increase and
frequently mention this and the more we
live we see it happening around us and
we're all heading towards this reality
of this life so yes I've seen many cases
I don't want to see many but you know
when it comes to something that I've
seen myself where people I've met you
live with you go to the Masjid with and
something happens and they die good
ending sometimes bad ending Allah knows
best
so may Allah forgive us steadfastness
but this is reality do you know my my
uncle he you probably do he would always
be at the juma hood bond Fridays you
were the Imam for some time dr.
Hashimoto vich yes I know everyone yeah
not too long ago it was a shock to all
of us he didn't let really anybody know
that he had stomach cancer and not too
long ago it's been a few months that he
passed away my lord grant him Jinnah
that was a shock to all of us because he
was someone who was healthy he was
someone who took care of himself he was
tying his camera as we say to take care
of everything on his side but he got hit
with the stomach cancer and he came it
was a shock to all of us and it just
happened so quickly and it was one of
those things I mean it was one of those
things that had hit so close to home
when it happened that it left me you
know someone might die that you know of
but it's not that close to home and you
might be following the funeral the to
the graveyard or whatnot you see that
and it kind of touches home but when
it's someone really close to you it this
feeling it just lasted at me for some
time it was just like the reality was it
was like it was it was more it was
something that I could feel more it was
very scary it was a scary feeling
because you know like okay that's me
next you lost someone that was really
close to you it was the closest person
to me that has died so far thus far it
was very scary do you know that feeling
was very scary alright and that's why
this is something that it is sufficient
for us to see they didn't the Quran and
the Sunna prophet asylum and the way
that Allah gave us the ability to think
that we as human beings the most the
major difference between us and the rest
of the creation of Allah is that we have
the ability to think of what's coming
out that's what makes us intellectual
really and what's coming ahead is
basically death that takes a person from
this life to the left and most of the
people are heedless they want to keep on
intoxicating themselves and to just to
have the joy of the moment but the fact
of the matter is as one of the early
generations of
he said that a few often if you were
forgetful and heedless
let's dive in more foolin Hank you are
not being treated with heedlessness
things would not change like someone the
exam is coming and he doesn't want to
take the burden of studying the exam so
he just enjoy his life and and don't
don't study well whether he's heedless
or not the exam is coming so it's not
gonna go to change anything if you're
enjoying yourself and partying and so on
death is coming it's not going to delay
it so better than to be to face the
reality of it and to prepare ourselves
for it and every day is a reminder for
us we're getting closer
so the real happiness which is as when
we're talking about that it's the most
fearful thing for anyone there is a life
but that most fearful moment becomes the
most joyful one if a person receives the
glad tidings from almost a note Allah at
that moment of death at that moment of
death is that where how would you
because that's what your expert on the
extra gist of extra Jesus of the Quran
the tafseer and where Allah talks about
those who believed in him and that when
death comes they will have no worry or
grief will be upon them right this is a
verse that allah so allah says in the
latina Boonen low semester como the
tennis that oh allah human mannequin
well latter half will a dozen that those
who say our Lord is Allah and then they
were steadfast upon the orders of allah
subhanallah al the angels come to them
meaning at the moment of death and let
the half or a dozen with two things
don't feel of what's coming ahead which
this is what comes into the mind when
and when we think about death and don't
have grieve of what you're leaving
behind your family your children
whatever there is so they would give
them the glad tidings and they would say
that we are the ones that support you
and so on they'll give them the glad
tidings of Jenna the Prophet array so to
sell him explaining this he said that
the meaning of which in the movement
they believer and that's what David even
when he dies and he sees good that he
receives the glad tidings from Allah
most high note Allah he doesn't want to
come back to this world anymore so this
life that were so much attached to and
when we think about death it scares us
the moment of death for the believers
receiving the glad tidings from allah
subhanaw taala doesn't want to come back
except the martyr the martyr is the only
one that wants to come
so that he's martyred again because of
the great honor that he receives so the
most fearful moment becomes the most
joyful one a person wants to go forward
he doesn't wanna go back to his family
to his children and all and all of this
as long as he was a believer and been
steadfast on the Deen of Allah so
instead of being worried about death and
talking about it in a sad way we just
need to face the reality of it this is
how life is and to be serious in this
life life is a very serious one it's not
a joke to be serious
to be obedient to Allah to do what is
right to fulfill the rights of others
our family needs our children they
convey the truth to be patient till the
moment of death comes and therefore a
person would receive what is good why do
you think it is that people have the
wrong impression when you do bring up
death that people they think okay if you
talk about death it's just something so
gloomy it's it's gloom its doom it's
like I don't want to hear about it
either someone will make a joke they'll
get kind of really uncomfortable and
they'll change the subject and even some
Muslims like when you say you bring it
up they're like come on you messing up
my mood should that be the attitude
definitely not because again this is why
people are just putting things off when
it's coming towards them it's a
continual you a person sitting by the
train track and the train is coming and
he doesn't want to face the reality that
it's coming it's gonna hit you so this
is why as Muslims we were ordered in the
Quran and in this one of the prophets
are seldom to be real and death the
subject of death should not make us
miserable should actually make us have
more reality to this life to have the
real happiness in it if a person
frequently remember death he would the
things that really enjoyable in this
life you will enjoy it which is the
obedience of Allah even the permissible
acts the things that people enjoy as
human beings will enjoy it if we do it
for the sake of Allah with without
committing sins and this will being a
loss final time lost parrot Allah even
mentioned death in the context of verses
that talks about the favours of Allah as
if death is a favour of Allah for some
individuals if they understand death in
the proper way has mentioned also before
in Surat al-rahman saluted Menelaus
final Tala mention in it many verses
shall be a year later become
Kathy Ben which one of the favours of
Allah would you deny
so it talks about the favours of Allah
but within the solar it says cooling on
AFN each and every one on its meaning on
the face of the earth will vanish will
die well how would you rob because you
read in Kalama and only the face of your
lord will stay meaning allah subhanaw
taala is at high
he's the everliving everybody would die
so this is mentioned in the context of
verses talking about the favours of
Allah so for the believers and it's only
for the believers it's a favor from
Allah and they depart from the miseries
of this life to the everlasting joy and
that's also the Prophet SAW solemn said
that that when a jenessa passed by and
he said are you so to some the meaning
of which either this is something in
most area most ilaha mean either he is
relaxing he's comfortable or the world
is relaxed as a result of his death
because he was a someone that is
spreading corruption and so on so either
or so therefore the believers they they
go to the to the comfort zone after
their death they don't wish for it of
course because this is against our
innate and our nature but what it
happens if they were believers in
steadfast upon the deen of allah and
repented to all those high note Allah
they will go to the real comfort not
this life this life is not comfortable
thing for them
this statement have you heard it and
what is him how would you explain it
where people who often hear it said that
people are asleep they're sleeping in
this life until death comes then they
awake right this is a true statement
that actually some of the origination of
assembly mention this people are not
flat they're asleep they're intoxicating
themselves is it a kind of a like a
spiritual sleep it's the it's the sleep
where a person is not aware of what's
coming ahead okay and people when they
think of death as you said it's
something gloomy as if it's not real
it's the opposite people would see that
this life was a delusion hmm and when
the moment of death comes it's more real
than this life it's more real and and
clearer than the fact that we're sitting
and looking each other and talking that
is not something cloudy or something
that is not needed so just some Souls
and things like this that people know
this is more reality than the fact that
we're living and eating and tasting and
so on
and that's what a loss panel Tyler says
in the Quran in surah kahf that when
death comes was yet second or two
notable Huck Vella comma contaminoid
hidden when the stubborn the stopper of
Death Comes the miseries and the agony
of death comes this is what you used to
avoid in your life and then it says like
a chef's knife a bus or locally Omaha
deed your cover will be lifted and your
eyesight will be hadid is like iron that
means your eyesight will be as nothing
before it's more reality more Awakening
than anything else
Wow so then we're working to be awake a
person who is using his logic knowing
that everything is deteriorating and the
human being I mean we've spent at some
time apart and you can just you
mentioned you know the the amount of
people that have died just everyday they
were that are in this life we're in this
life they're going somewhere and Islam
gives you the blueprint and tells us
have you come across any other way of
life that goes over the details from
when the Angel of Death Comes to when
death comes to what goes on after that
everything is laid out because that
would be unjust if the creator didn't
tell us these things but he's warned us
he's given us the answers to the test I
have not come across and I'm a student
of comparative religion looking at the
other religions and for the sake of Dawa
but have you come across anything other
than Islam that lays out such a detailed
explanation of the details of death and
the Hereafter
there's no such a thing as the you would
find in the Quran and the Sunna of the
Prophet SAW said Allah that makes it
really very clear and it's it is very
something that as we find in the
verbatim word God the Quran and the and
the from the Prophet Muhammad example no
right there's nothing there like no
because this is the final revelation
from Allah sanatana the most
comprehensive and anything that we need
to know from the hereafter that would
make our life according to allah spanner
to Allah wants Hamas he would find it
explained in so much details have have
you ever heard this this argument
someone says I'll deal with it when it
happens well this is maybe can
in matters of this world that we live in
and sometimes it's true when the person
is concerning himself about something
that is there is no need for him to be
concerned about it now wordly things
materialistic things but when it comes
to the purpose of our life there's no
such a thing as I'll deal with it later
later meaning in this and Hereafter
there's no actions to be done it's only
he said reckoning and today is actions
and there's no reckoning there's no
punishment yet or a reward in this life
so when the moment of death comes the
person would wish to come back to fix
what he made of mistakes but it's too
late and that's also mentioned in the
Quran so that nobody would regret they
grow they regret is already explained in
the whole and some verses in the film
when you recite them that talks about
person dying and you would say or not
build your own well my lord let me
return back you would feel when you're
reflecting upon these verses you put
yourself in that situation so you feel
regretful as if you are in that
situation so you would face the reality
that it's not there yet so let me do
something before I regret so the Quran
gives us clear instructions and ways so
that we do not regret we were discussing
in the message today and for the past
few days
solo dr. Han Solo to table on a table or
means the loss and gain that people have
in their buying and selling
imagine someone a child has a diamond
the most expensive one he would go to
sell it for a candy bar he doesn't know
the value of it so if someone exchanged
something very very valuable for
something that has no value whatsoever
he would feel that great loss people
would be like this in the EFT when they
see that the meta was so easy for them
to be to receive the general of Allah
subhanAllah
it was so easy to be obedient to Allah
but they wasted it for what for
temporary joy that it's not really doing
the believers are more joyful actually
in this life than those who are
intoxicating themselves in it there's a
lot of distractions out there and there
is one distraction that's distracting a
lot of people and it's kind of like
people almost taken this material thing
as a god in and of itself I want to get
your reaction to a short clip and then
from there you can give me give us your
thoughts so now we can drive some
benefit hopefully she'll
I'm doing okay you know I ain't doing
number living life you know I live a
great life lavish life keep apart you
have to keep a pocket full of money as
you can see what's up TMZ under
Mayweather zone the money's on whatever
y'all want to talk about speaking about
it speaking about that money so today we
see a lot of this flash we see it a lot
of this bling-bling and people seem to
be hypnotized by the money so how do we
find a balance where what's Islam's view
on money and how does Islam approach
this when you take it too far
that it kind of blinds you to this
reality that we're talking about see the
religion of Islam speaks to our Fatah to
our pure nature that Allah is finite and
I created this with and people sometimes
they take themselves away from this pure
fit on our pure filter I would say
clearly that again this is all something
that is not going to be forever
the Deen of Allah subhanAllah Allah
mentions wealth and so on and and this
is something important in life and there
are many verses in the Quran that talks
about the importance of it but put it in
the right perspective is that a mean or
a goal the goal is the purpose of our
life is to worship Allah subhanAllah
evacuator they have engineers and they
mean to achieve that one of which is
money and wealth and a lost panatar I
mentioned in the Quran that we are
greedy so we know that as a fact so we
need to overcome this greed by giving a
small portion of it which is the
mandatory like this occur for example to
give it for the sake of Allah and to
help the needy and the poor and to
understand that this wealth can be
either a mean for the person to the
Hellfire or to the general hospital town
or whether a person spend it in
something that is spreading corruption
in the face of earth or something that
is good and at the same time not to be
enslaved to it it brings all kinds of
misery the Prophet SAW salem as you
referred to this hadith
he said ties after dinner ties Abdul did
not rise up Dork ateva ties Abdul camila
ties means that he is miserable the one
that is a slave of durum like the Money
cash money whatever there is
the sleeve of the cloth and the sleeve
of different types of wealth which is
gold silver would be like the material
of fashion right we qualify right and
that's why we can add to this anyone
there is a slave to any materialistic
things the prophets of Salem was not
mention it as a way to say this is the
only things but as an example of the
materialistic things of this world and
then he said that is sort of sentence I
want a castaway the sheikah Verlander's
which means he's miserable he's always
inverted he's not upright he see things
not in the right way because this had as
you said they've 'no ties the person not
able to see what is right and what is
wrong because of the desire to this and
he said that if he is harmed the
smallest harm he becomes really
miserable because this is what he's
worshiping basically but if a person
takes it as a mean and we know that this
life there's ups and downs and some
people they at certain moments of their
life they're very rich and then what
happens to them if they become very poor
commit suicide you know this is a sign
that this is not the right way to deal
with with wealth and so on many people
was sitting with her brother this
morning he was he had a good job and so
on and so forth and then all of a sudden
he doesn't have anything and he's not
feeling happy which is a normal thing
but when you wrote when you look at it
with your own Fatah and nature and you
look into the hadith of the Prophet SAW
Solomon the verses of the Quran who said
that you will be guaranteed to have a
good day life materialistically all of
you in time life this as they say at
dunya Jubilees talakad ah this dunya
this world is based on Qatar meaning
it's not something comfortable you
always have to have ups and downs so
this is that you already know the
reality of this life so I make yourself
heedless of this yeah so what do you
what is your reaction because this is
this person individual is probably one
of the most popular people out there
that a lot of youth follow and you'll
see people like this really showing off
the extravagant lifestyle so how do you
qualify because it's not just let's say
if you worship a human being for example
like Jesus if you worship a saint if you
worship anything in creation other than
the Creator that
would be associating partners to God
this would be like buying you or free
giving you a free ticket to the Hellfire
correct now money how does that or
living the lavish lifestyle
how do would that qualify you because we
do like nicer things but what's the fine
line that you don't transgress that
limit and make money into your God where
you become a slave to it
this the guidance to this is in the fall
and in this another prophets asana it's
explained clearly in the Koran in the
example of Karan Karan was from the
family of Musa listen and he was given
wealth that the Quran explained is in
such a way that the strong among men
they are not able to carry the keys of
his treasures hmm the keys you know keys
usually one key can carry so much
treasure the keys are the treasure the
strong men cannot carry even the keys so
you can imagine how much wealthy he was
and when when it with regards to this
karoon the people they split into two
groups which what we see today the Quran
is something that as if it's revealed
today for the people those who are
living today so the Quran says one Quran
Quran came out on to his people what did
the people say the foolish ones the
masses of the people they said the l8l
ni miss lemon would hear karoon in our
little half of an RV they said we wish
we have what karun has because indeed he
has a great fortune this is what most
people are they get their hearts
attached to this they wish they have the
like of it they would imitate these
types of individuals the other group of
people the people of knowledge called
alladhina you to the ELMO alikum so my
hyrulean menemen army lost money they
said to the people the people of
knowledge and it's mention the Quran the
people of knowledge specifically they
said woe to you what the fair web and
the reward from allah subhanaw taala is
better for you if you believe and do
righteous good deeds well I will acquire
loss swabby rule and only the patient
ones would have this and achieve this
but then the story takes us to the end
of it because we're trapped to the
moments where this is at most level of
excitement in there but then when we
live longer we'll see what happened
after 50 years to that individual or
this video
things will be totally different so
the same thing happened to karoon unlost
Hinata and I destroyed them and
destroyed his worth and the people again
they said when they saw this that they
wish they knew the truth before for
hisself Nabil we did it up so a lot of
our data destroyed him and the people
they said yeah well they would that I
said they were woe to us or something
more or less of the meaning that they
wish that they know this so always the
people of knowledge they know before
things happens because they know from
the revelation from Allah the rest of
the people if they don't listen to the
method to the subject of knowledge ease
into the way of Allah they will know it
but it might be too late I already had
if you had a sit-down you had an
opportunity to talk to someone like this
a Floyd may money may they call Floyd
money Mayweather or someone famous like
that what kind of things what would you
tell them first of all we'll need to
have mercy inside of us and we should
not rush into being harsh of course yeah
and we as as Muslims and as the prophet
o Salaam was sent as a mercy to mankind
who need to have that mercy in our
hearts towards all humanity definitely
would advise him with all kinds of
sincerity and truthfulness and kindness
that we as human beings we need to think
what is the purpose of all of this no
hate is the most important thing if a
person doesn't have the oneness of
worship of allah subhanaw taala doesn't
follow the Prophet SAW said Allah what's
goodness in this life to make them
understand that this is from Allah los
Maradona is the one that bestowed this
favor upon you and he's the owner of all
things and as a clear evidence very
simple one that doesn't need too much
intellect to know then that when we die
we don't take any of this with us so the
one that gave us this is Allah and when
we depart it all returned back to Allah
spinal tap
so to be grateful to him the ones I gave
you the health the one that made you
live on the face of earth to be grateful
to him and that is to worship Him alone
and to put things in perspective and
remember what happened to those who were
arrogant on the face of earth reading
the stories about them are they still
alive till today till their arrogance
and their happiness and rejoicing over
these things availed them or benefited
them in any way or form they get old and
they died or they get destroyed
whatever there is and at the end nobody
would wish to be in their position
whatsoever and that's why we always have
to think of what's the end result and
this is where the heart has to be
attached to now someone says well all
you religions out there you say the same
thing you know what I mean I believe in
God but I'm gonna follow my way I'm
gonna do my thing is that acceptable
well if it's exact if it's acceptable
then there is then this is basically
attacking the essence that the creator
of the heavens and the earth is the most
wise he won't leave his people like this
the creation of a lot to be heedless
that's why he sent messengers and
revealed books and since he's the most
wise he won't leave things according to
our own desires because we know that our
own desires is very deceiving so that's
why there is something for people to
examine and to read the Quran I find the
revelation from Allah Spano town looking
to reflect into what is this message of
the whole and which is basically
something that a person would see that
it fits his again his fit oh we need to
you know very importantly that when
people read for example the whole end
sometimes they have their own means of
understanding that they would judge the
Quran according to their thinking and
according to their background of
knowledge and culture and so on no we
should invite people to read the Quran
with being a human being
leave all of these into distractions in
your life and be a human the way that
unlost Hinata Allah created you with
your filter with your pure innate and
this you would find that the Quran is
addressing this and you would see
definitely the truth and not what you
have already from your own distractions
that you built over years now go back to
as a human as a simple human being that
you would find the common thing between
us all of us as human beings whether you
are in the jungles in Africa for example
in the Amazon or or you are the most
sophisticated in some degrees we are
humans and there is something that
brings us all together this is what we
need to be in that level so that we
would see the reality of things without
all of these distractions didn't have
some beautiful advice purpose of life
everything has a purpose think about
that and then turn to the the one who
created life and seek the guidance I
mean
and not ascribe foolishness to the most
wise that he wouldn't create us and not
have a purpose for us to live I think
it's simple it's easy to understand
right yeah and go back to your own self
don't be distracted don't be tempted by
the desires of this world at the end of
the day when a person is alone we cannot
deceive ourselves and that's what the
message of the Quran is that's why when
I lost Hannah and I sent the messengers
and the messengers will say to the
people worship none but the one that
created the heavens and the earth we
know for a fact that this is something
that nobody can deny and if they deny
with their speech they are basically
lying to themselves they're covering
their own pure in need that is inside
that allah subhanallah wants from them
now we covered the lot of the spiritual
I call it the stds the spiritually
transmitted diseases that affect us and
which given the cure for that now there
is another thing with touch upon before
we conclude
what's also affected us when you look at
the staggering
mind-blowing statistics to the
second-most greatest blessing from the
Creator is our health and you see for
instance share and we'll get your
thoughts on this where they're
estimating about a hundred million
people in America today are either
pre-diabetic or they have diabetes you
have one in two Americans has a chronic
disease that's half of America one in
three and multiple chronic diseases one
in two men are one in two females and
one in three males are expected to have
cancer and this is what hit my my uncle
and it's and it's it's something that's
hitting it look 50% of people expected
to have cancer amongst men and then one
in three I believe in women or it's the
opposite way around thirty percent of
kids have chronic diseases these are
kids and this is the first generation of
kids that are not expected to outlive
their parents so with all these
staggering statistics many doctors I've
spoken to holistic doctors people you
know pioneers in this
new they are linking the majority of
this 95% they say to the food so how do
you when you look at first as the Quran
in pseudo bucket I where Allah the
Creator to heavens the earth was saying
to eat of the good food
the tehy bat so that kind of goes over a
lot of people's heads like is it free
where Shaitaan has until the end of time
right to take as many people to the
Hellfire is this a means that's off
limits
is this the altering of the food you
know the fake foods the toxic foods all
of these things what what is Islam how
do we get into you know this is this is
such an important topic where we'll see
so many Muslims affected by this also is
because the word were also in the
general population but nobody's really
talking much about it in Islam if a
person is in any form of a business or
transaction he is ordered to have the
concern in his heart towards others and
one of the basic things that the
Companions of the Prophet SAW seldom
would give the pledge to the Prophet
when they are becoming a Muslim is to
have this most out of this concern
towards every single believer meaning
when we talk about the food and the
alteration of it and all of these
poisons in it who made out of this it's
not a lost phenotype is the human beings
it's the greed of the human beings hmm
and that's what the you know the cause
of all corruption on the face of earth
is our sins is the sins of the people is
the greed of the people money becomes
the ultimate goal the lives of the
people is secondary
how much money I would make and that's
why you would find government's imposing
certain rules and restrictions otherwise
if they leave it like that to the people
they don't mind to kill the entire
country for them to make billions of
dollars or whatever there is so
therefore this is the the corruption
that happened to the human beings needs
to be reformed again and there's the
only way to do that is to seek reward
someone most high note Allah I don't and
it is not easy to be concerned of others
and to continue to be like that when the
person is greedy unless the person is
doing things for the sake of Allah so
the only way out of this is to to be
upright and to be faithful and to seek
reward
donnatella by being kind to others so if
each and every individual is conscious
about this they want to talk to hitters
and that's why if this is not happening
then a person should do the best he can
that he can you know to consistently be
upon the Tibet and the pure and to be
warned against the greed of the human
beings he no claim the the great scholar
and his work I see him it seemed like he
was just way ahead of his time he talked
about so many relevant things and he
actually talked about health you know he
talked about the medicine from the Sunda
he talked about a lot of these thing one
that sticks to mind he was talking about
when someone is granted this gift of
health how much that person should
preserve it how much they should protect
it you came across these statements from
him right and just creating awareness
that many of us we end up not thinking
so a person will indulge in alcohol
something that's clearly you know Haram
you know people will indulge in
cigarettes gorging doing all sorts of
putting all sorts of junk in their body
as if a law created a garbage can right
but it's not a garbage can so you know
really helping people to wake up to
honor this gift that Allah has given us
that it's gonna get us through life and
is this a duty upon every Muslim right
human being I'm especially when we
always talk about the purpose of life
everything has to fall in place with
that purpose what is the purpose the
purpose of our life is not to enjoy this
life that's not the purpose the purpose
of life is not to keep on eating and
accumulating wealth and so on these are
all means to fulfill the purpose and
that is to worship Allah subhanAllah
so if we look at food or whatever there
is or our health that this is a mean for
us to worship Allah spano to Allah alone
things will be different our perspective
to things will be different I remember
few week weeks back I was with one of
the scholars and we're visiting a sick
person and they were discussing and he
has cancer and it's very terminal and so
on so they were discussing whether he
should do in radiotherapy or not and the
Sheikh mentioned very interesting
statement regardless of whether this to
be done or not but he mentioned that if
we can take the means according to the
knowledge that we have for that
for that person to to make more Victor
to almost panel to Alan to be aware of
things around them so that would help
him to make Vicky register for for
whatever days left in his life it's a
good thing so the concern is the goal of
this life so even when we look into
medicine and things like this is it
going to improve my health
for what reason why I want to be healthy
profit any sort of ceremony would go
visit a sick he would make dua to almost
my entire life with that sick one of the
interesting dua that he would say a lot
of mushy out back a few lame-o Allah
cure he was slave so-and-so and he would
mention his name for what reason
Yankel acardo why I'm Shalaka you know
fish Allah so that he would defeat his
enemy and he would walk to the Sala for
you sake
that's why we want him to be healthy not
to be healthy and spend more years and
in following his desires and being
sinful but rather to use this health to
go to the Masjid to mix Allah to make
the words of Allah Spano died last
period and that's the benefit of health
otherwise it becomes against the person
I remember you told me so the Dean
doesn't leave anything out actually
addresses many of these things I
remember you telling me years ago I
still stuck with me to today you
mentioned a hadith where a man came to
the prophet saw something I was amazed
he said I feel tired or Messenger of
Allah and the prophets also told him to
go run go running remember that
everything and the silent to go is like
something between running and walking
like jogging and they used to complain
to the Prophet SAW Selim that it makes
their they feel lazy or tired he told
them to do this and and it's known that
you you do is from from running it helps
to people called the runner's high when
you're running and then it helps to
physically actually there is people of
knowledge where they compiled the
subject of 40 hadith because of hadith
of the Prophet SAW solemn
that whoever compiles 40 hadith who the
people like the 40 hadith mmm no and
others so some of them they mentioned
even 40 hadith in physical exercise dead
from the Sunnah of the Prophet SAW
seldom to encourage the person to be
physically active for the purpose of
preserving one's health now when we go
back for we conclude this when we say
taiyi but can we
okay what would be the proper
translation can we say okay this is
halau pure good real food we can say
that yes of course because I play a bit
and the type is something that is pure
there are something that has no filth in
it in this essence of no sense and no
filth no impurities nothing would serve
the opposite of what the food is for so
anything that negates the purity of a
climate it's something that a person
should stay away from whether it's in
the Haram sense or something that is if
not Haram but still a person has to be
very careful of what he is intakes are
has to be fewer that benefits him
physically and spiritually and
everything in love the opposite I get
amazed when I talk to a lot of these
these holistic doctors or nutritionists
who really study food and they talk
about how food it can actually be a
healing for the body it's like a
medicine and you had like famous people
from the past talk about let food be
your medicine and medicine be your food
but then you answer the question that
anything that Allah created when you
offset that balance that stuff that's
killing the people is not the stuff
Allah creates the people who have put
the chemicals modified it changed it and
the greed that's motivated this is
what's messing people out right and even
the the hadith of the Prophet SAW seldom
whoever eats something Haram and any
flesh that grows from the Haram the
Hellfire will take care of it
I mean if a human others when they
talked about this they said when you
when your body grows from Haram that
portion that grows from Haram is evil is
impure it will be punished in now fire
unless a person repents to Allah Spano
tile and he mentioned something
interesting he said that means there's
something physical this growth
physically is not a good growth because
of the Haram that a person would take
inside so this is something for people
even to check themselves you know there
is something physical wrong in the
growth of a person if his intakes are
wrong if what he's as far as what even
whatever for Haram mr. O Hara and of
course anything else also that would
undermine the purpose of this life
yes Shay I want to thank you for finding
the time to be with us there's so much
we'd love to talk more about for you
with you hopefully inshallah we can have
you back any last advice for the people
tuning in to the Dean Shaw do you like
to give all I advice to myself and
everyone is as we see time is going and
we need to be steadfast on the Dean and
don't be distracted and sometimes it's
important and especially in the life
that we live in with all of these
distractions to to be silent unless
proven otherwise don't do things that a
person would regret it later rather to
focus on the most important things our
Dean our Ikeda or believe our prayers to
give charity to be kind the basic things
the matters of the Dean who need to keep
on being firm upon it and that by the
will of Allah Spano Donna would help the
person to reach us for in destination in
good inshaallah very concerned and thank
you guys for tuning in we covered a lot
and we started off and we'll end with
the remembrance of the destroyer of all
pleasures so you can flaunt that money
and that lavish lifestyle but as our
guests so wonderfully explained that's
something that you're gonna have to
leave behind it all stays behind so get
it right now and think what's my purpose
everything around me has a purpose but I
the human being don't have a purpose and
who's best to tell your purpose then the
one who created us for a noble purpose
the creator of the heavens and earth
hope is you liked this episode subscribe
if you haven't already and tune in every
week here to the Deen show until next
time peace be with you
Salaam alaikum